Parliament committees have herdin
questioned commissioners designate
Oliver of a Haley Adina yawen Avalon and
Thierry Bhutan on neighborhood and
enlargement transport and the internal
market MEP s from the Foreign Affairs
Committee quiz Oliver Vahey the former
ambassador of Hungary to the EU is up
for the neighbourhood portfolio I intend
to increase the pace of structural and
institutional reforms with a strong
focus on the fundamentals of the rule of
law economic development the functioning
of democratic institutions and public
administration reform MEP is questioned
by Haley on how he plans to accelerate
enlargement talks with the Western
Balkans in the current political context
and what will be his stance on eu-turkey
relations
some of them voiced concerns over how
he'd promote the rule of law and remain
independence from the Hungarian
government if confirmed as commissioner
after the hearing the committee
coordinators decided to ask him to
answer more written questions
Idina Johan over LAN for the transport
portfolio was met by the transport and
tourism committee the Romanian MEP
currently chairs Parliament's industry
committee we must make all transport
modes sustainable and for that we need
not to only improve our standards but
you must also ensure that clean mobility
solutions are widely adopted and
deployed questions from MEP s focused on
how to combine an efficient transport
plan while reducing its impact on
climate her positions of tourism the
single European sky and support for
businesses were also scrutinized Berlin
successfully passed the parliamentary
hearing the portfolio of internal
markets has been proposed to tle were
torn from France the ex-minister
technology writer and former head of
well-known companies was interviewed by
the internal market and Industry
committees
any piece focused their inquiries on
possible conflicts of interests given
his past career in industry and his
vision for the future of the internal
markets yeah Yoshio acapella Quesada
Duma on average T small T $200
technology 3gpp2
obviously on a song he knew she focuses
precision and at Alicia's artificial or
cloud a diva or bashed cloud wrote on
successfully passed the parliamentary
hearing the vote in parliament to decide
if the commission as a whole is accepted
or rejected is scheduled for the end of
November
[Music]